Móa chẳng đường tám biến năm, đây giang khó, nhưng hào hùng.
Chúng ta đã khả bị chân liy,
giới ngọn cơ vinh quán của đàn,
quên sáng hủ chí mình sôi đường,
dừa vào xích mạnh nhất dân và khối đại loàn thiết toàn rất tập.
Không có khó khăn thử thách nào,
mà nhất dân tháng không vượt qua,
không có một tiêu câu đẹp nào,
và rất tập tán không đặt ở ý.
Chính vì vậy, không có lực cả nào,
không có lý rau dị có thể ngăn vước chúng ta
vứa tự hòa vình thịt vợ dân tập ta chương tồn và phát triển.
Vướng tới tương lai,
đàn tà đặt một tiêu đến năm 2020,
kỳ điểm một trong lắm thành lập nước.
Viet Nam là khúc ra hùng cường thịt vợ khách phúc,
nó là khách vọng của cả rất tập,
là là thế dân dự trước, trước, mình sử, trước như dân,
tôi kêu hỏi toàn đàn,
quan thân, quan thân, quan đồng vào phát, trong nước,
và ngoài nước.
Màn yến vệ làm khu thề, kia thật,
hãy đoàn kết, chúng sức, nóng lòng,
biến khách vọng thành hẹt hợp.
Lỗ lực thân nước,
quyết tâm hơn nước,
phát triển cao đồ chỉ tôi sức sáng cao,
và bản lính, vệ Nam,
thực hiện tháng lời,
các cuộc tiêu nhiều buồn mà đàn nhả nước đã để ra,
nhên rất, mong đời.